لم تغرهم الصحراء بافق اللام منتهي ولا
برابها واساطيرها الغابره انهم يرون فيها
حزم الدولار واليورو يجنونها من تهريب سلع
متنوعه تبدا بالسجائر والبنزين والسلاح
وتنتهي بالمهاجرين والمخدرات هذا النوع
الاخير هو ما يستوقفنا اليوم تهريب
المخدرات جعل من الصحراء جنه للمهربين ومن
دول الساحل ممرا نحو الثراء السريع وغير
الشرعي هل يكفي بعد الصحراء عن الانظار
لتفسير لجوء مهربي المخدرات اليها ام انهم
يجدون في بعض الدوائر الرسميه هناك ما
يسهل مهمتهم المره تلو الاخرى الفيلم
الوثائقي طائره وديبو الذي بثته الجزيره
محاوله للفهم
والاجابه بدا الامر بحادثه غريبه شهدتها
مدينه نواذيبو الموريتانيه منتصف عام 2007
طائره مجهوله قادمه من اعماق المحيط
الاطلسي تحط في مطار المدينه دون سابق
انذار قبل ان تغادره على عجل بعد عده
دقائق مخلفه وراءها مئات الكيلوغرامات من
الكوكاين لمن الطائره ومن اين جاءت وكيف
تمكنت من الهبوط في مطار رسمي وما هي
الجهه التي كان يفترض ان تستلم حمولتها
المشبوه والى اين انتهى مصيرها هي بعض من
اسئله سعت الحلقه الاحدث من برنامج
الجزيره الاستقصائي الصندوق الاسود
للاجابه عليها لكن التحقيق الذي حمل اسم
طائره وذبو لم ينجح فقط في تتبع خيوط تلك
الطائره الغامضه وانما ايضا في كشف بعض من
معالم الدور الخفي الذي باتت تلعبه دول ل
السحل الافريقي في التجاره العالميه
للمخدرات فالحرب التي شنتها الحكومه
الامريكيه على تجار المخدرات في امريكا
اللاتينيه منذ مطلع ثمانينيات القرن
الماضي دفعت المهربين للبحث عن خيارات
بديله لنقل بضائعهم الى الغرب الهشاشه
الامنيه الفقر المدقع المساحات الشاسعه من
الصحار الخاليه من البشر ضعف مؤسسات
مكافحه الفساد توفر الاموال اللازمه لشراء
الذمم وعلى اعلى المستويات عوامل اسم في
تحول دول غرب افريقيا الى ممر رئيسي
للمخدرات القادمه من امريكا اللاتينيه الى
اوروبا بحسب مكتب الامم المتحده لمكافحه
المخدرات والجريمه فان قيمه المخدرات
المهربه سنويا عبر دول الساحل الافريقي
تقارب مليارين و400 مليون دولار ارقام
تغري على ما يبدو كثيرا من الجهات لمحاوله
اقتطاع نصيب منها فتحقيق الجزيره يكشف
كذلك عن التواطئ بين تجار ومهربي المخدرات
ودوائر رسميه امنيه وقضائيه وسياسيه
احيانا في تلك الدول في حادثه طائره واذ
بو مثلا ورغم الضجه الكبيره التي اثارتها
القضيه فان ثمه دوائر نافذه سعت للتكتم
عليها وابقائها بعيدا عن الاعلام واروق
القضاء
فالمفترض
وكشف بان شحنه المخدرات كانت قادمه من
فنزويلا وانها تخص سيدي محمد ولد هيداله
وهو ابن رئيس موريتاني سابق هذا المفتش تم
عزله وتجاهل تقريره اما المسؤولون والضباط
الذين اوصى بحالتهم للتحقيق فتمت ترقيتهم
حسب الوثائق فيما تمكن المتهمون الرئيسيون
في القضيه من مغادره البلاد ولم يحاكموا
الى
اليوم وللحديث عن هذا الموضوع انضموا
الينا من نواشط الدكتور سليمان الشيخ حمدي
مدير مؤسسه رؤيه لدراسات واستطلاعات الراي
ومن باريس صديق ابا الكاتب الصحفي في لمون
افريق سيد صديق ابا ابدا معك ما الذي يجعل
من منطقه شمال غرب افريقيا ممرا رئيسيا
لتهريب
المخدرات نعم المهربون انتبهوا الى ان
افريقيا الغربيه تمثل نقاط ضعف في
المنظومه هناك بلدان لا تستطيع ان تراقب
مجالها الجويه او
سواحلها مثل غين
بيساو او الراس
الاخضر هي ضعيفه في تنظيم عمليه مراقبه
الاجواء
والبحر
والمربون قرروا استغلال نقاط الضعف لنقل
كميات هائله من المخدرات في الساحل الغربي
لافريقيا وبعد ذلك عن طريق شاحنات
الى افريقيا الشماليه ثم الى
اوروبا طيب دكتور سليمان السيد ابا يتحدث
عن نقاط ضعف هناك في تلك البلاد ما كشف
عنه وثائق الجزيره مما كشف عنه استخدام
طائره بوينج احداها حملت طنا كاملا من
المخدرات برايك ما الذي مكن المتاجرين الى
ذلك
الحد شكرا جزيلا بخصوص ملف المخدرات او
قضيه المخدرات في غرب افريقيا يجب ان يوضع
في سياقه الواقعي ذلك ان مهربي المخدرات
لما شددت عليهم وطئه المحاربه الامريكيه
بالذات حاولوا ان يجدوا طرقا بديله ليس
بالضروره يعني ان يجدوا ارضيه مناسبه لكن
هي طرق بديله كانت الاسهل من ضمن عده
خيارات اخرى طبعا كان الاوفر حظا لان
يتبوا هذه المكانه هو غرب افريقيا اول شيء
لانها مطله بدون حدود على امريكا
اللاتينيه مصدر هذه المخدرات بالذات غنا
بيساو رس الاخضر سنغال مالي سنغال قصدي
موريتانيا فكان اختيار هذه البلدان ليس
فقط يعني لا يمكن نعلق الموضوع انه فقط هو
هشاشه النظام الامني في هذه البلدان او
تواطؤ الجهات الحاكمه فيها بل ان المخدرات
اصلا لا تبحث عن تواطؤ رسمي معها في بلد
معين لان هذا يسلط عليه الاضواء اكثر فهي
تعمل في الخفاء من خلال الفساد منظمه
الفساد التي تجتاح بعض الدول والتي لا تخل
منها اي دوله سواء كانت غربيه او افريقيه
او غرب افريقيه وبالتالي هي استقلت هذه
المنظومه الفاسده واستطاعت ان تمرر
شحناتها لكن لكن بالرجوع الى هذه حادثه
طائره نواذيبو عندما نجد ان نريد ان نضعها
في سياقها نجد انه فعلا كان هنالك ذكاء
وهو ليس مستبعدا على مهرب المخدرات لانهم
استغلوا فتره كانت فيها موريتانيا يعني
للتو يعني مستلمه فيها سلطه مدنيه وصفت في
الغالب لانها ضعيفه ا للسلطه لذلك فكانت
هذه الفتره تعتبر فتره هشه للامن لانه لما
الاستراتيجيات القديمه مع نظام وطائع قد
زالت ولم يتم بناء استراتيجيه جديده رغم
هذا رغم هذا كله كانت الطائره التي حاطت
في نواذيبو طبعا من اين جاءت الاخبار
الطائره التي حاطت في نواذيبو كانت امريكا
هي التي ا اوعزت الى السلطات الموريتانيه
الامنيه بان الطائره ستكون قريبه من
موريتانيا في تلك الحدود لكن ولكن اعي الت
دكتور دكتور سليمان بان مثال طائره
نواديبو او هذه القصه هي مثال لتسليط
الضوء على هذه الظاهره التي انتشرت في تلك
البلدان فقط دعني انتقل الى السيد ابا من
باريس لنوع التوقيت يبدو ان تقاطعا
للمصالح يجمع ما يسمى المنظمات الارهابيه
ومنظمات تهريب المخدرات رغم اختلا
المرجعيه الايديولوجيا وحتى المصالح
العامه ما الذي يجمع بينهما سيد ابا
برايك
وعم جرام هو هي
الجريمه
المنظمه المخدرات والسجائر و تجاره البشار
لان هناك اعمال
حول الهجره غير الشرعيه
وجميع الاطراف يعملون جنبا الى جنب وعندما
ناخذ المنظمات
الارهابيه على الساحل الافريقي هي
تاخذ رسوما على
المرور للمخدرات وغيرها من المواد غير
الشرعيه وايضا
الانتداب اذا مجموع المنظمات الارجيه
تتعاون فيما بينها سواء كان مهرب المخدرات
او السجائر
او تجاره البشر او الاسلحه ايضا كل واحد
يقوم باعماله الى جانب الاخر
وهناك التقاء مصالح وكما قلت ضعف البلدان
تسهل كل ذلك طيب دكتور سليمان تقارير
الامم المتحده ومنظمات اخرى اشارت الى
تقاطع المصالح هذا ما الذي يبقيه يبقي هذا
التعاون بعيدا عن الضوء وبعيدا عن
ملاحقه اعتقد انه تحالف المصالح بين مهربي
المخدرات والجماعات المسلحه في شمال مالي
وفي غرب افريقيا بشكل عام يسلط الضوء على
انه فيه قوى اجنبيه كبرى لا تريد ان تسير
في النفق حتى النهايه لانه المخدرات معروف
منشاها ومعروف اين تصل هي منطقه غرب افريق
مر منطقه عبور ثم هنالك بعض التقارير تقول
انه حتى فيه يعني شحنات اسلحه تاتي مع هذه
المخدرات
للجماعات المسلحه في في غرب افريقيا لكن
الشيء المحير هو انه لماذا
تنصب تقارير الامم المتحده وتقارير الدول
الكبرى على منطقه غرب افريقيا فقط دون ان
ت ان تتطرق الى ان تلك المعلومات متداوله
ومنشا تلك السلع المهاره هو امريكا
اللاتينيه وانها عبرت على المحيط الاطلسي
كله عبرت من فوق المياه الاقليميه
المراقبه امريكيا عبرت من لماذا لم يتم
اعتراض هذه الشحنات في عرض البحر قبل ان
تدخل الى وسط الى غرب افريقيا اعتقد انه
الموضوع يدخل في سياق اكبر من هذا انه
منطقه غرب افريقيا بوصف منطقه فيها ثروات
كبيره لا يراد لها الاستقرار بالتالي لا
تحارب فيها المخدرات بقدر ما تترك ك شماعه
يمكن التدخل فيها في هذه الدول يمكن اسقاط
انظمه من خلالها يمكن فرض عقوبات على
انظمه يمكن ان تدار من خلالها السياسه
الدوليه في هذه المنطقه وبالتالي هذا هو
الوجه الحقيقي للمخدرات اما ان يتم تسليط
الد فقط على طائره او شحنه او كذا فاعتقد
انه يعني اجتزاء للموضوع
يعني في الحقيقه يعني طيب سيد صديق ا
الحرب على الارهاب ان كان في افغانستان
سابقا او حتى في دول شمال غرب افريقيا لم
تشمل الحرب على تجاره المخدرات رغم تقاطع
المصالح هذا ورغم التقارير التي تقول ان
مخدرات احيانا او التجاره بها تكون مصدر
للتمويل لماذا
برايك
[موسيقى]
princi في الاساس عندما
تحدث
عن الساحل
الافريقي جزء من شمال افريقيا وبلدان
مثل شمال مالي وشمال النجر هناك الحرب ضد
الارهاب مدعومه من الجهات الدوليه فرنسا
والولايات المتحده و
بالنسبه البلدان الاولويه هي محاربه
الارهاب وليس
محاربه تجاره
المخدرات وهم يتركون البلدان الافريقيه
تهتم بهذا الامر
ويحاولون التعرف على المجموعات
الارهابيه بدلا من ان
يضعوا الحرب
ضد الارهاب وضد ايضا المخدرات لكن البلدان
والمجتمع الدولي يركز على الحرب ضد
الارهاب وذلك ما
تستغله العصابات او المنظمات تجاره
المخدرات وغيرها ولكن لا يمكن الفصل
بينهما اذا اردنا ان نكون فاعلين وان نحقق
نتائج ينبغي ان الحربان ان الحربين يكونان
معا ومتوازي والا سنظل في نفس الوضع طيب
دكتور سليمان الشيخ حمدي اعود الى ما
ذكرته عن دور الدول دول شمال غرب افريقيا
واقتبس مما ورد على لسان احد شخصيات
الوثائق عندما قال هذه الدول ليست مصدرا
للكوكايين ولا تستهلكه حتى وبالتالي فقط
مناطق عبور اين الضير في الاستفاده من
رسوب رسوم التهريب اذا صح التعبير هل هذه
العقليه موجوده حقا وكيف يمكن تصدي لها
اذا كانت
كذلك اعتقد ان هذه الع
موجوده بقدر ما موجود بقيه الجرائم الاخرى
في اي مجتمع انه فعلا هنالك مهربي مخدرات
يغلوا هشاشه المجتمع يستغلوا بعض الثقالات
الامنيه في تكوين قاعده قويه لوجستيه خاصه
في السنوات الذهبيه لهذه التجاره وهي 2007
2006 2007
2008 واستقلوا فعلا يعني هذه هذهه الثغرات
لكن بعد ذلك لا يمكن نتكلم عن عن عن ظاهره
حقيقيه يعني مثل ما يدور في امريكا
اللاتينيه او يدور في افغانستان مثلا حرب
الكوكاين التي تنتظم فيها قبائل تنظم فيها
عش في بالنسبه لغرب افريقيا وخاصه
موريتانيا الموضوع لا يعدون يكون جرائم
منظمه طبعا تقف وراءها مافيا كبيره اكبر
حتى ميزانياتها من ميزانيات الدوله تستغل
كل الوسائل تستطيع ان توقع ببعض المسؤولين
تستطيع ان توقع حتى ببعض الامنيين لكن اخذ
طائره بهذا الحجم في منطقه نواذيبو او
قريبه منه يعتبر على الاقل نشح امني لا
يوحي بتواطئ يعني على مستوى القمه وعلى
مستوى المستوى المؤسسه الامنيه وان كان
يحي بتقصير امني او بضعف في البنيه
الامنيه ان صحت التب اشكرك جزيلا دكتور
سليمان الشيخ حمدي مدير مؤسسه رؤيه
للدراسات واستطلاعات الراي كنت ضيفنا من
وكشط الشكر موصول كذلك لضيفنا صديق ا
الكاتب الصحفي في لوموند افريك كان معنا
ضيفا من باريس بهذا نصل الى نهايه الحصد
الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ن